et avec nous dans ce club des
territoires Pierre Jacques m
bonjouronjour vous êtes rédacteur en
chef du magazine Politis et on accueille
également Nicolas pris bonjour
éditorialiste politique à la tribune
dimanche on va revenir avec vous sur la
crise agricole qui a été marquée hier
par la mort d'une agricultrice et de sa
fille sur le barrage d'agriculteur de
Pamier en Arriège un drame qui ajoute de
la tristesse à la colère actuelle des
agriculteurs notamment contre les normes
environnementales et Steve cette crise
agricole et bien elle exacerbe les
tensions entre le gouvernement et les
oppositions oui on ira dans le chaudron
de l'Assemblée nationale Gabriel Atal
qui tape sur la gauche et sur l'extrême
droite mais d'abord on va aller
direction Toulouse pour revenir sur ce
drame dans le département de la riège on
va retrouver nos partenaire de la
Dépêche du
[Musique]
Midi et on va retrouver nos partenaires
du journal La Dépêche du Midi avec Éric
berger qui est rédacteur en chef adjoint
à la Dépêche du Midi en duplexe de
Toulouse bonjour Éric bonjour Alors vous
revenez longuement aujourd'hui dans la
Dépêche du Midi sur ce drame qui s'est
déroulé hier dans le département de
laariège
oui un terrible drame qui effectivement
a a jeté la consternation l'effroid
parmi les agriculteurs mais bien au-delà
de de cette corporation ça s'est produit
aux environs de 5h30 du matin à Pamier
sur la RN 200 pour des pour une raison
encore indéterminée que l'enquête pourra
peut-être éclaircir assez rapidement une
voiture est parvenue à franchir les
barrières qui pourtant interdisaient
l'accès à cette nationale 20 et signaler
qu'il y avait un une coupure un blocage
de l'autoroute enfin de la route
nationale organisée par les agriculteurs
et la voiture s'est engagée à vivealure
sur la nationale et a fini par percuter
un mur de paille et une famille
d'agriculteurs qui se trouvaiit à
proximité le bilan est en effet très
lourd avec la le décès d'une
agricultrice de 36 ans de sa fille de 12
ans qui est décédée en début de de
soirée et puis le père de famille et lui
très grièvement blessé on n sait pas
beaucoup plus sur les circonstances de
ce de ce drame à priori il n'y a pas de
caractère intentionnel qui pour
l'instant a été retenu mais le le
véhicule n'aurait pas dû se trouver sur
sur la nationale on sait aussi que les
trois occupants sont des des personnes
de nationalité ménienne qui a priori
faisait l'objet d'une OIG obligation de
quitter le le territoire elles sont
actuellement en garde à vue et
évidemment ben ça a jeté vraiment la la
consternation parmi les les agriculteurs
on est allé dans le village dont la
famille est originaire famille très
appréciée on a entendu les paroles et
l'émotion du maire du village lui-même
agriculteur et dans la soirée le
ministre de l'Agriculture Marc fenau
s'est rendu à Pamier pour rencontrer des
agriculteurs urs des élus faire part lui
aussi de son émotion alors il y a pas eu
d'annonce forte de la part de de Marc
PHENO qui a toutefois indiqué que des
annonces seraient faites assez
rapidement d'ici la fin de la semaine a
priori en tout cas il y a une forte
attente des agriculteurs c'est ce qu'on
a pu aussi constater sur l'autre gros
barrage de la région sur la 64 au sud de
Toulouse à carbone où les agriculteurs
qu'on a pu rencontrer disent au-delà de
l'émotion qu'ils attendent vraiment des
décisions très fortes sur tous les
points qui ont été déjà les
revendications des agriculteurs qui ont
déjà été annoncé sur le prix des
carburants sur la réglementation les
normes écologiques et puis au-delà de ça
les questions de revenus des
agriculteurs un petit point en
particulier c'est pas un hasard si
l'Occitanie est vraiment l'épicentre et
le point de départ de de ce mouvement je
rappelle que c'est la première région
agricole de de France et que dans leur
grand grande majorité on a beaucoup de
petits exploitants de petits éleveurs
qui disent au fur à mesure de de nos
reportages leur difficultés à joindre le
debout les debout et avoir une
trésorerie décente en fin en fin de mois
et en tout cas on voit bien leur
détermination après ce après ce
drame on en est où ce matin des barrages
d'agriculteur en ocitané alors le
barrage sur la nationale 20 à Pamier a
été levé dans la journ
à la fois par solidarité vu l'émotion
des agriculteurs et puis pour les
besoins de l'enquête en revanche partout
ailleurs on constate que la mobilisation
est toujours très forte c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'avait annoncé le patron de la
FNSEA Arnaud Rousseau disant que la
mobilisation allait s'emplifiée et tout
autour de Toulouse et bien il y a encore
des points de blocage notamment sur la
64 à carbone d'où tout est parti mais
aussi dans le tarnégaron il y a la
centrale nucléaire de de golfèche dont
les accès sont empêchés sur plusieurs
axes autoroutiers tout autour de
Toulouse dans le lotégaron dans le
tarnégaron dans l'ode également on voit
que la mobilisation ne faiblit pas et
puis en plus aujourd'hui à Toulouse on
peut s'attendre à d'autres perturbations
parce qu'il y a aussi un mouvement de
grogne des taxis sur d'autres
revendications d'autres problématiques
en tout cas on voit bien que il y a une
forte attente et qu'il va falloir que le
gouvernement réagisse très très vite et
fasse des annonces fortes et rapides
merci beaucoup Éric berger pour toutes
vos explications Éric berger en duplexe
de Perpignan et on va regarder la Une de
La Dépêche du Midi aujourd'hui consacrée
à cette à cette agricultrice et à sa
fille tuée hier sur un barrage agricole
merci beaucoup Éric pierrejcquemain
après ce drame de Pamier hier cette
crise agricole prend une nouvelle
dimension c'est encore plus sensible
pour le gouvernement oui c'est encore
plus sensible pour le gouvernement
gouvernement après vous l'avez dit ça
ajoute à la colère la tristesse s'ajoute
à la colère la tristesse je crois
qu'elle est vécu aussi quasi
quotidiennement par beaucoup de
d'agriculteurs et d'agricultrices qui
vous le savez on le dit suffisamment
sont une profession plus sujette au
suicide et donc du coup le
deuil des des familles de de paysans est
quasiment quotidien ça rend les choses
d'autant plus lourdes et graves que
effectivement le toute une profession et
euh et en colère mais c'est pas une
colère qui qui émerge seulement
aujourd'hui c'est une colère qui euh qui
existe depuis au moins les années 70 que
la crise agricole rencontre un certain
nombre de problèmes on sait qu'il y a
plus de 100000 exploitations qui ont
disparu depuis Ann depuis les années 70
et que donc du coup les revendications
qui sont celles et qui sont pas les
mêmes he parce que aujourd'hui on voit
un monde paysan très mobilisé mais qui
qui est aussi très divisé de par les
revendications euh il y a la FNSEA qu'
entend beaucoup mais il y a aussi les
petites exploitations qui sont
représentées par d'autres types de de
syndicats ou de structures associatives
qui revendiquent pas les mêmes choses
donc il faut aussi savoir entendre
quelles sont les revendications parce
qu'on entend d'un côté il faut plus
d'aide d' l'autre côté il faut moins de
moins de contraintte et de normes mais
tout le monde ne revendique pas les
mêmes choses donc il faut savoir aussi
entendre quelles sont les revendications
et je dis je voulais dire une dernière
chose c'est que euh sans doute le
gouvernement va-t-il réussir à calmer
peut-être un certain nombre de euh de
d'attentes notamment celle de la FNSEA
en faisant un certain nombre de
propositions mais le le le le mal-être
le le le le mode de fonctionnement de
notre agriculture c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est un chantier colossal
qu'il faudrait ouvrir et que
malheureusement le duo infernal FNSEA
gouvernement ne fait pas ne fait pas
naître justement un nouveau type
d'exploitation un nouveau type
d'agriculture aujourd'hui dans notre
pays et le chef du gouvernement Gabriel
Atal qui a promis des réponses rapides à
la colère des agriculteurs est-ce que ce
drame ce décès de cette agricultrice et
de sa fille Nicola Prisset et bien ça va
mettre la pression pour que gabrielal
accélère encore plus dans ses réponses à
apporter oui évidemment ce type de
circonstance absolument dramatique pour
un un exécutif ça fait partie des des du
pire des scénarios quand vous avez un un
un mort dans une manifestation dans des
rassemblements qui sont des
rassemblements de de protestation et
d'appel à l'aide du gouvernement et bien
nécessairement ça change le climat ça le
temps et et ça met une notion d'urgence
supplémentaire pour pour l'exécutif donc
là on a des un calendrier qui semble se
préciser pour Gabriel Atal avec des
réponses qui serai un début de réponse
qui serait apporté en fin de semaine et
puis ensuite peut-être des des projets
plus plus structurels pour son discours
de politique générale mais en tout cas
pour l'exécutif c'est évidemment
l'urgence absolue du du moment arriver à
à calmer la la tension la la pression
qui vient des des campagnes pour pouvoir
ensuite pour Gabriel Atal et ben dans
des
circonstances un climat un peu meilleur
au moment de lancer les projets qui qui
seront qui seront précisés la semaine
prochaine au discours de politique
générale donc évidemment la c'est
l'urgence du moment on peut imaginer que
l'exécutif il consacrit l'essentiel de
de de son énergie est-ce que il y a les
ingrédients dans cette crise agricole
pour que ça dégénère comme ça a dégénéré
avec la crise des gilets jaunes en 2018
ou encore avec la crise des bonnets
rouges contre lesécotaxe en 2013 pierre
je je je sais pas il faut rester prudent
parce que c'est vrai que la France a
connu un certain nombre de mobilisation
où on peut se dire que les Français ne
sont plus aussi euh enfin non'ont plus
assez d'énergie pour se mobiliser encore
que on voit bien qu'il y a une
accumulation d'annonces qui font ou qui
qui enfin ces annonces font
qu'effectivement la colère il y a un
germe de cette colère alors certes on
voit en Allemagne la l'importance des
mobilisations qui ont encore repris
d'ailleurs hier et qui vont encore se
conformé conforté aujourd'hui en
Allemagne ça fait Tage d'huile dans
plusieurs pays d'Europe notamment en
France on voit que cette mobilisation
quand bien même d'ailleurs si le
gouvernement fait un certain nombre de
propositions pourrait durer la question
effectivement après les les annonces de
Monsieur le Maire de dimanche dernier
sur la hausse des tarifs de
l'électricité euh après la la la la la
décision d'augmenter le le le les les
les soins médicaux enfin il y a un
certain nombre de de de de décisions qui
sont prises par ce gouvernement qui
pourrai effectivement euh fâcher un
certain nombre de Français on voit
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
d'anciens leaders des gilets jaunes qui
disent vouloir remettre le gilet jaune
et de re rejoindre les agriculteurs sur
les rond-points donc oui sans doute il y
a quelque chose de de de de de de de
l'ordre de la colère sourde ou froide en
tout cas qui qui existe dans ce pays on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui l'inflation la
colère des agriculteurs et d'ailleurs
enfin ce qui ass ce qui assez fascinant
j'entendais hier un agriculteur dire que
il y avait pas d'agrégation des colères
mais le monde agricole ou le monde
professionnel tel qu'il s'est mobilisé à
l'occasion des des gilets jaunes ce sont
deux ce sont de ce sont deux ce sont
deux endroits de la chaîne qui se
rejoignent d'un côté les consommateurs
de l'autre côté les agriculteurs qui
sont là pour nous nous apporter
l'alimentation tion à notre pays et donc
il y a forcément une convergence en tout
cas de de de de de points communs de de
de de convergence d'idées de convergence
d'intérêt aussi donc je c'est possible
qu'il y ait une mobilisation qui prenne
source à la base de cette mobilisation
des agriculteurs et dans quelques
minutes on va suivre la conférence de
presse des sénateurs les républicains et
du tête de liste LR aux européennes
François Xavier Bellami sur cette crise
agricole mais d'abord Nicolas Prisset
est-ce que dans la gestion de cette
crise par le gouvernement on sent qu'il
y a le traumatis de la crise des gilets
jaunes le traumatisme que vous évoquez
il existe depuis la période des gilets
jaunes et il est ravivé à chaque fois
qu'il y a un moment de de tension
sociale en France c'est vrai que pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est c'est une période
ça a été des moments extrêmement
marquants et une sensibilité depuis du
président de la République qui a voulu
multiplier ce qu'on appelle les les
capteurs locaux pour essayer de sentir
et de de de prévenir les les les risques
de tension là ça n'a pas été le cas
enfin ça né pas été le cas mais disant
que ça aurait peut-être pu être même
pire dans dans le l'appréhension du du
gouvernement Emmanuel Macron a été
alerté et sensible et assez rapidement
euh sur le sujet des des agriculteurs et
donc le on a une prise en compte par
l'exécutif qui qui qui qui n'a pas trop
tardé euh et avec aujourd'hui des
rendez-vous qui sont pris et puis des
des annonces qui sont faites on vient
d'évoquer donc pour Emmanuel Macron il y
a évidemment cette crise des gilets
jaunes qui reste un marqueur qui l'a
rendu beaucoup plus sensible au risque
de contestation sociale mais euh là on
est dans une situation on peut pas
vraiment comparer avec les gilets jaunes
les gilets jaunes il y avait une mesure
initiale très clairement identifiée qui
était la la la taxe sur le le l'essence
dans le cadre de la transition euh
écologique et et et qui a cristallisé
les tensions avec un mouvement euh
absolument imprévisible et pas du tout
organisé là il y a des syndicats
agricoles qui sont peut-être un petit
peu dépassés euh néanmoins dans le dans
le mouvement de conestation euh qui ne
représente pas forcément très bien euh
les intérêts de de leurs agriculteurs
euh mais on n'est pas dans un mouvement
de type gilet jaune qui serait
incontrôlable ingérable et totalement
spontané non plus euh la différence
effectivement c'est qu'il y a pas de
revendication extrêmement CLA et précise
de la part des agriculteurs c'est un un
ensemble de de de choses qui qui
s'agglomèent et puis qui qui font qu'à
un moment la coupe est pleine euh on
parle notamment pour revenir peut-être
des taxes mais aussi des des normes qui
sont élaborées par l'Union européenne
dans le cadre de la transition et qui
cristallise une partie des des tensions
mais il y a pas un élément dont le
retrait par le gouvernement ferait que
la crise s'arrêterait immédiatement et
puis vous l'avez évoqué pierre il y a
des raisons très profondes au mal
agricole très français que personne n'a
voulu traiter au depuis des années et
qu'il faudra peut-être un jour prendre
en compte alors on va tout de suite voir
la conférence de presse des sénateurs
les républicains et du tête de liste LR
aux européennes sur cette crise agricole
et Anne Sander nos députés européens du
PPE qui ont beaucoup travaillé tout au
long de la mandature écoulée sur ce
sujet brûlant et bien bien sûr je
remercie Laurent Duplon pour sa présence
il est non seulement l'auteur d'une
proposition de loi
transpartisane donc pour la
compétitivité agricole donc en faveur de
la ferme France et puis dans la dans la
nuit depuis hier les équipes de la
commission des affaires économiques avec
les administrateurs que je remercie ont
travaillé d'arrache-pied pour faire une
proposition de loi avec 42 mesures qui
donc tend à répondre à cette crise
agricole et je laisserai bien sûr
Laurent vous faire cette présentation de
cette proposition de loi qui est toute
chaude et qui vient juste de de sortir
de des bureaux de la Commission des
affaires économiques donc je suis très
très heureuse et je salue nos
commissaires de la commission des
affaires économiques qui sont venus
nombreux également assister à à ce point
presse donc je vais juste vous dire
quelques mots d'introduction et puis je
passerai bien sûr la parole
immédiatement à François Xavier bami et
à Anne Sander alors le constat d'une
agriculture européenne et d'une
agriculture française qui entravait par
un excès de de fiscalité par un excès de
de réglementation mais aussi par une
complexité administrative abérrante
n'est malheureusement plus à faire et
dans ce contexte les manifestations
auxquelles nous assistons depuis
plusieurs jours en France et plus
généralement en Europe non'ont hélas
surpris personne dans notre famille
politique les républicains mais
également au niveau de notre groupe au
Parlement européen dans le Parti
populaire européen le PPE ce constat
c'est celui des injonctions
contradictoires à l'origine desquelles
se trouve Emmanuel Macron et ses
gouvernements successifs et le groupe
renew ces injonctions contradictoires on
le voit aujourd'hui le gouvernement
soudainement fin de soutenir nos
agriculteurs à Paris alors que depuis 5
ans à Bruxelles il fait exactement
l'inverse je laisserai dans quelques
instants et je l'ai dit François Xavier
bamie et Anne Sander qui ont énormément
travaillé sur ces sujets nous donner un
certain nombre d'exemples et nous faire
le retour des travaux qu'ils ont menés
tout au long de la mandature écoulée
mais c'est ces exemples qui vont
malheureusement illustrer ce en même
temps ce mode de fonctionnement qui a
été érigé aujourd'hui en système et ce
sont nos agriculteurs qui en subissent
les aement à tel point que cela les
conduit à un découragement et surtout à
une véritable désespérance ensuite je
voudrais simplement rappeler ce qu'a
fait la commission des affaires
économiques au Séna et là aussi la
Commission depuis de nombreuses années
n'a pas attendu les manifestations qui
se déroulent aujourd'hui dans notre pays
dès 2019 c'est la commission des
affaires économiques du Sénat qui avait
pris à à à bras le corp la question au
combien sensible et difficile du
mal-être dans le monde agricole en
particulier chez les éleveurs dans un
contexte d'agribaching pesant très
fortement sur le moral de la ferme
France et nous avions dès 2019 émis un
certain nombre de recommandations pour
traiter ces questions au combien
difficiles avec humanité et bon sens et
puis c'est en 2023 et je le disais dans
mon introduction que à la faveur d'une
proposition de voilà pour le début de
cette conférence de presse des
républicains sur la crise agricole une
crise agricole qui devient très
politique et justement on va en parler
avec vous Steve puisque hier à
l'Assemblée nationale aux questions au
gouvernement et bien le Premier ministre
Gabriel Atal s'en est pris vivement il
est en première ligne face aux
oppositions oui des oppositions qui
clairement tentent d'enfoncer un coin et
hier c'était évidemment le sujet de la
mobilisation des agriculteurs qui
occupaent tous les débats le contexte
est particulier he puisque cette séance
intervenit quelques heures après le
drame survenu en Arriège et c'est
justement une députée du coin Martine
Froget qui a interpellé le gouvernement
depuis plusieurs mois la colère des
agriculteurs éclate au grand jour ce
n'est pas une colère épisodique mais le
résultat d'anné de concion de vie
inacceptable combien d'autres drames
suicid ou accident faudra-t-il pour
qu'enfin nos agricultures soient
entendus même tonalité offensive à
l'extrême droite où depuis plusieurs
jours on essaie de s'emparer de ce
dossier des agriculteurs en colère le
rassemblement national a accusé le
gouvernement de soutenir une politique
agricole dictée par l'extrême gauche
écoutez nous vous alertons depuis des
mois sur cette France rurale et du
travail qui n'en peut plus vous
continuez à soutenir FEM tout fork cette
feuille de route européenne d'e d'une
écologie punitive et de décroissance
agricole dictée par les pires
écologistes d'extrême gauche alors Steve
est-ce que gabrielal a fait des annonces
hier en direction des agriculteurs non
non rien de concret la parole de
gabrielal était pourtant scrutée de très
près lors de ces questions au
gouvernement mais c'était une parole
très politique dans son viseur d'abord
la gauche et la nupes écoutez parfois
vos larmes pour nos agriculteurs
ressemblent à des larmes de crocodiles
vraiment parce que la
réalité c'est qu'à chaque fois que nos
agriculteurs que nos éleveurs familiaux
ont un projet d'extension de leur
élevage qui s'y oppose vos amis avec
votre soutien à chaque fois qu'un projet
est lancé dans notre pays sur une
retenue d'eau pour lutter contre la
sécheresse sur des investissements pour
nos exploitations ce sont vos amis qui
s'y
opposent voilà ça c'était pour la gauche
il y en a eu aussi pour le rassemblement
national écoutter le Premier ministre et
donc je le dis il y a aussi une lucidité
face à ceux qui butinent de colère en
colère en donnant le sentiment qu'on
pourrait sortir de l'Union européenne le
26 décembre quand les pêcheurs en colère
angoissés étaient en train de créer leur
revendication on na pas vu monsieur BZ
là on a vu madame Lisianne metthyer
député de cette majorité qui elle
n'était pas en vacances qui était sur le
terrain avec
eux une mise au point qui fera à coup
sûr beaucoup de bruit sur les réseaux
sociaux mais face à la crise Gabriel
Atal devra faire davantage le Premier
ministre poursuit les consultations avec
les syndicats agricoles il a reçu hier
la Coordination Rurale il s'entretient
ce matin avec la Confédération paysane
il faut faire vite mardi prochain
déclaration de politique générale ça
serait mieux pour lui qui est pas de
fumier ou de tracteur autour du
Parlement merci beaucoup Steve pierre
votre réaction à ces attaques de Gabriel
Atal sur les écologistes qui dénoncent
leur larme de crocodile pour les
agriculteurs bah c'est desevant c'est
desant parce que moi j'espérais que
Gabriel allait imposer un nouveau style
parceque on annonçait un jeune à la tête
de ma style quand même là il y a un
nouveau style vous trouvez dans
l'hémicycle vous trouvez vraiment très
offensif en cas très offensif de laition
attendez gabrielal gabrielal fait de la
politique mais il fait de la politique
par la communication alors certes il a
le verbe fort il a des formules toutes
faites il a des punchin qui vont bien et
qui font plaisir à nous-même les
journalistes mais c'est pas comme ça
qu'on s'adresse à son opposition enfin
l'opposition qu'elle soit de gauche de
droite encore que l'opposition de droite
ça c'est marrant même de le dire puisque
ce gouvernement est de droite donc tout
ça assez rés mais on s'adresse pas comme
ça à son opposition quand on traverse
une crise comme celle-là on peut pas
dire dans un moment aussi grave que
celui-là je vais entendre tout le monde
d'ailleurs souvenez-vous Gabriel a dit
je vais consulter toutes mes oppositions
et y compris les syndicats pour pouvoir
écrire mon discours de politique
générale comme s'il attendait d'avoir
reçu Mathilde Panau et Sophie Binet pour
pouvoir écrire son discours de politique
générale et au moment où se pose des
questions d'actualité dans un parlement
sans prendre à la gauche avec autant de
virulence et autant de violence non je
trouve que il y a qu même quelque chose
qui est quand même assez frappant hier
vous avez suivi vous qui aimez les
débats parlementaires les les les
discussions au Parlement sur sur la
crise que connaît aujourd'hui le monde
agricole je trouve assez hallucinant de
voir la droite la macronie aujourd'hui
dire rendez-vous compte on a une
politique totalement ubuess qu'on va
acheter du des B des bœufs ou des des
beau vins en Argentine alors qu'en
France on a ce qu'il faut et cet ça
s'appelle les marchés de libre échange
qui a voté les March les traités de
libre échange à l'échelle européenne si
ce n'est la droite et la macronie de
renue c'est complètement surréaliste on
voit des personnalités de horizon qui
ont qui sont membres de cette majorité
sufusqué aujourd'hui de de la manière
dont on marche sur la tête sur le marché
mondial de l'alimentaire c'est c'est
quand même totalement délirant ce sont
ces mêmes personnes qui gouvernent qui
produisent aujourd'hui les les travers
que et les la crise que traversent
aujourd'hui des agriculteurs Nicola
Prissette la stratégie du gouvernement
c'est détourner l'attention vers
l'opposition et notamment vers les
écologistes la stratégie du gouvernement
alors juste je vais vous répondre mais
juste un point pierre l'essentiel des
échanges agricoles ils se font à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne donc
peut-être qu'il y a des menaces qui sont
ressenties comme tell vis-à-vis des
marchés mondiaux il y a aussi un traité
qui a été certes négocier mais pas
ratifier justement sans doute peut-être
avec la pression des des agriculteurs
qui qui voulait pas donc
merérence au Mercosur donc donc
l'essentiel des échang ça nous a pas
empêché de signer avec levec le Canada
avec
d'autres rentrer dans le débat technique
mais la proportion de de
d'importation de viande qui sont lié à
ce type de de contrat est quandme assez
marginal par rapport à ce qui se passe
en terme d'échange à l'intérieur de de
l'Union européenne donc bon on peut on
peut avoir des débats techniques mais
pas vraiment
techque concret mais mais bon je je
pense pas que ce soit le point
principal écologist c'est pas un peu la
cible facile pour Gabri c'est la cible
facile surtout pour les agriculteurs il
me semble les les écologistes Gabriel
Atal lui il sait très bien que les
agriculteurs ils ont voté Macron en 2022
ils ont ils avaient déjà voté Macron
assez largement en 2017 c'est un
électorat qui est assez fidèle au
président de la République mais qui est
aussi courtisé et on le voit on l'a vu
très clairement le weekend dernier par
le rassemblement national donc pour lui
il y a dans ce jeu où il va attaquer qui
à la fois l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche il y a aussi l'idée de de de
garder euh ce soutien politique
électoral si tantit que ce soit bien le
cas aux européennes des agriculteurs
donc ça c'est c'est les équilibres
politiques il ils sont là
après le l'électorat agricole oui bien
sûr il peut être euh dans une
disposition d'esprit négative voir
agressive vis-à-vis de certains
écologistes pas tous parce que pour une
partie de cette de ce monde agricole je
dis bien une partie parce que c'est très
hétérogène il y a le sentiment que on
vient leur imposer des normes qui sont
ubuesqu et qui les empêchent de
travailler bon ça évidemment on on on
peut l'entendre et c'est toujours humain
d'être sensible à des ce type de
revendication et et chacun déteste être
pris comme une espèce de cobaille par
l'administration mais mais en dehors de
cette réaction qui fait le lit du du du
populisme il y a aussi dans le monde
agricole et bien une grande difficulté à
à prendre en compte ce qui sont les les
évolutions de de la modernité et la
nécessité de faire la la transition et
pour cette transition peut considérer
qu'ils sont plutôt mal accompagnés mal
accompagnés en interne et mal
accompagnés par les pouvoirs publics et
là il y a vraiment un enjeu de politique
qui est majeur qui a un enjeu de fond
qui se résume pas à des bisbill autour
d'un texte ou autour d'une
réglementation mais qui est la la la
prise en compte générale de cette
transition que doit mener l'agriculture
justement on va écouter l'écologiste
Yannick jado qui était invité politique
du jour dans cette émission et il
répondait aux critiques du Premier
ministre Gabriel Atal contre les
écologistes qui défendent ces normes
environnementales je pense que c'est
irresponsable euh c'est lâche et c'est
assez minable en fait euh le Premier
ministre visiblement continue c'est pas
une nouveauté avec ce pouvoir
malheureusement ça fait suite à d'autres
gouvernements à une totale
irresponsabilité en matière
d'agriculture je veux dire le
dérèglement climatique c'est la
catastrophe absolue quand il fait vous
le savez bien quand il fait 40 45 degrés
par canicule au niveau du sol des vignes
c'est comme si vous mettiez un coup de
chalumeau sur le raisin il y a plus
d'eau mais pour et donc qu'est-ce que
dit qu'est-ce que dit le Premier
ministre il dit mais tout ça c'est la
faute des écologistes tout ça c'est la
responsabilité il trouve un bouquet
missère plutôt que de travailler à des
solutions alors le gouvernement a aussi
tensé un autre adversaire politique le
rassemblement national d'ailleurs le
patron du parti Jordan Bardella qui est
en campagne EUR
et vraiment monté au créneau sur cette
crise agricole le weekend dernier il
était et bien au côté des agriculteurs
pour dénoncer et bien je cite l'Europe
de Macron pierrejacquemain on est dans
la pure récupération politique de la
part du RN de toute façon même Jordan
Bardel le dit lui-même n'importe quel
terrain sur lequel il il serait tenté
d'aller tout tout est àorté de main pour
lui parce que il
serait il serait le grand gagnant de
toutes les séquences politiques que l'on
traverse qu'elle soit agricole qu'elle
soit sociale qu'elle soit économique
ologique c'est-à-dire que on a tellement
fabriqué un un un un un parti avec
Marine Le Pen que on disait que Marine
Le Pen était devenue féministe qu'elle
été européen qu'elle été sociale qu'elle
étaé écologiste que maintenant Bardella
porte les fruits de tout ça donc
effectivement partout où il va on a le
sentiment que il en sensé de partout il
y a une chose de vrai hein je suis pas
sûr que ça se confirme encore
aujourd'hui en France mais la
mobilisation en Allemagne et au Pays-Bas
est partie d'un monde agricole très
proche de l'extrême droite je ne crois
pas que ça se vérifie vérifie totalement
en France ce qui s'est passé hier en
tout cas dans le déplacement de Bardella
qui est allé à la rescousse des pêcheurs
qui sont mis en retrait de de leurs
activités pour sauver les dauphins j'ai
pas entendu une voix de Jordane Bardella
une proposition de Jordan Bardella si ce
n'est même de reprendre la terminologie
de la gauche qui parle de d'exception
agriculturelle voilà donc non en fait la
la l'extrême droite fait de la
communication mais sans proposer sans
faire de proposition il nous reste peu
de temps pour conclure Nicola pris cette
crise ça faire le jeu du RN en tout cas
il essaie de la récupérer puisque c'est
une crise où les agriculteurs
àuxell à ce momentl rembl national cé
des agriculteurs dans son eurcepticisme
donc c'est assz assez banal finalement
et est-ce que ça
sera payant juin prochain j'en suis pas
convaincu parce que il y a toujours de
la part des agriculteurs la conscience
que sans cette Europe ils auraient pas
autant de débouché et en tout cas cette
crise agricole fait aussi la une de nos
quotidiens régionaux c'est la r press
des
territoires
Steve à la une de nos quotidiens
régionaux et bien ce mouvement
d'agriculteur qui fait tâ d'huile oui on
va voir toutes ces unes ce matin le
mouvement a débuté en Occitanie jeudi
dernier il s'étend désormais à toute la
France l'Alsace titre sur ses
agriculteurs en colère et cette gronde
qui gagne dans la région l'ardenet fait
un point sur les blocages qui auront
lieu aujourd'hui dans le département
même mobilisation en charant tout le
quotidien du coin s'intéresse au
tracteurs qui sème la pagaille en
organisant notamment des opérations
escargot le main libre se penche lui sur
les agriculteurs qui sont et bien bien
décidés à faire monter la pression dans
le département de la Sarte et que font
les Bretons bah vous allez me dire vous
êtes bretons non les Bretons passe à
l'attaque clairement c'est la unee du
télégram autour des Bretons de ce
mobilisés ils ont rejoint hier le
mouvement de protestation ils occupent
le terrain notamment à Quimper pour
réclamer des solutions pour les
agriculteurs le Télégramme parle d'ors
et déjà d'une mobilisation sans
précédent pour la région à noter que les
pêcheurs on en parlait tout à l'heure
qui eux aussi sont en colère pour
d'autres raisons viendront prêter main
forte aux agriculteurs ce jeudi on est
peut-être là dans une fameuse
convergence des luttes le gouvernement
va guter ça de très près avec ALIR aussi
un retour sur cette tragédie d'hier dans
le département de l'Ariège oui c'est à
la Une de La Dépêche du Midi une voiture
à foncée hier matin sur le barrage
agricole dressé à Pamier bilan très
lourd une mère et sa fille sont décédé
on nen sait plus sur les occupants du
véhicule qui arrivit de Toulouse et
roulé vers l'endor il s'agirait de trois
personnes de nationalité arménienne sous
le coup d'une qtf le caractère
intentionnel de la collision n'est pas
privilégié pour le moment alors Steve
autre sujet on termine sur une ambition
politique oui celle d'Arnaud robinet le
maire de reince qui veut rempiler il
était un temps pressenti au gouvernement
pour être notamment ministre de la santé
il accorde un entretien au journal
L'Union aujourd'hui et annonce qu'il
sera bien candidat à sa réélection dans
dans 2 ans il promet qu'il n'est pas
aigri de ne pas être entré au
gouvernement mais se demande quand même
si l'étiquette de son parti horizon n'a
pas été un frein dans cette ambition et
puis on finit avec une dernière note
sportive oui note positive c'est la
journée internationale du sport féminin
ce mercredi l'est républquain fait la
une sur ces femmes d'élite qui font
gagner leur club en handball en
volleyball en rugby reportage à
barlededuc et à Nancy notamment où les
équipe féminine ont pris le dessus sur
les hommes elles sont devenues la
vitrine de leur club Alex en tout cas
vous Steve votre sport c'est plutôt le
Padelle maintenant un peu de foot moi
j'ai arrêté le foot le padle maintenant
c'est le padle merci beaucoup à Steve
pour votre revue vue de presse c'est la
fin de ce club des territoires merci
Pierre-Jacques main d'y avoir participé
merci beaucoup à Nicolas Prisset
pierre-jacquesemain on va regarder la
une du magazine Politi une une consacrée
à la guerre entre Israël et le Hamas
avec ce titre après l'attentat
terroriste du Hamas la dérive fasciste
de Benjamin n oui on fait le point sur
la situation à Gaza et on revient aussi
sur la situation 6 Jordanie qui est un
peu le le le le cœur du problème en ce
moment avec les colons qui qui n'hésite
pas à
utiliser les méthodes les plus dures
merci monessieur c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous sur Public Sénat à
18h avec votre émission sence publique
présenté par Thomas HUG on se retrouve
demain à 8h notre invité politique sera
Annie jeunevard la députée les
républicains on parlera de l'Ave du du
Conseil constitutionnel qui sera donné
demain sur la loi immigration très bonne
journée sur Public
Sénat